this is tumor hussein reading for
preview of randolph ramsay metroid red
doesn't waste any time in introducing
what exactly there is to tread in the
long awaited sequel many of the game's
trailers so far have featured the long
limbed quadrupedal robots known as emmys
who seem to be near impossible to kill
sentries that series protagonist samus
aran must simply avoid emmys or at least
one version of them are there right from
the start of your adventure and during
my recent hands-on playthrough of the
game's opening sector emmys proved to be
an effective compelling way of
instilling a healthy amount of panic to
the series's tried and true core of
action and exploration granted the last
game in this specific metroid series
metroid fusion which was released a
whopping 19 years ago featured a similar
nemesis-like unstoppable enemy in the
sax but while the sax was merely a
chilling presence in limited and
scripted spurts the emmys in dread
looked like there will be a much more
present and constant threat in my
hour-long playthrough the winding path
of progress took me through enemy
patrolled areas several times which
meant repeated cat and mouse-like
encounters although my time with the
game was brief it was enough for me to
feel twinges of anxiety every time i saw
one of the telltale shimmering black and
white doors that indicated an emmy was
somewhere on the other side
[Music]
but let's take it back a step and frame
where metroid dread takes place within
the wider series dread is officially the
fifth game in what nintendo terms as the
2d saga which started with the original
metroid on the famicom way back in 1986
or 1987 for the nes the series which
also includes metroid 2 super metroid
and metroid fusion charts the story of
bounty hunter samus aran and her
seemingly intertwined fate with the
species known as metroid as well as her
encounters with a parasitic lifeform
known simply as x a whole bunch of space
pirates and a mysterious extinct or are
they civilization known as the chozo
it's a lot to remember especially as
this story has taken 35 years to unfold
it's no wonder that metroid dread makes
sure to catch you up on the narrative so
far with a brief recap right at the
start of the game the intro gives some
necessary background along with a
healthy dose of mystery the dangerous x
parasite thought to have been wiped out
after the events of metroid fusion have
been spotted again on the planet zdr the
galactic federation sent a team of
robotic emmys to search for the x but
they have been mysteriously corrupted
now it's up to the hyper-capable samus
iran to figure out exactly what happened
to the emmys and to confirm if x is
again a credible threat adding to the
mystery is an unidentified chozo warrior
who promptly whops samus's butt the
minute she lands on zdr stripping away
most of her abilities before abandoning
her at the bottom of zdr's extensive
tunnel system and yes that means that in
a break from the usual metroid tradition
samus has to work her way up instead of
down during the game despite the forced
ability reset samus is still a sprightly
bounty hunter at the start of dread and
controlling her as she moves around the
opening sector of actaria is a breeze
her new ability to slide under low
obstacles makes early movements
especially zippy this mobility is her
key defense against the aforementioned
emmys while the first emmy you'll
encounter is broken and only serves as a
tutorial showing how emmys can be
destroyed once you get a rare power up
the second is much more ominous it's
fully mobile moves quickly can scale up
walls and ceilings and is totally
impervious to samus's weapons in metroid
red it seems that enemies will be
limited to certain areas within each
sector emmys patrol their designated
zones sending out sonic pings visualized
by yellow circles on the screen to
detect sound or movement once they
detect something they'll quickly
investigate and if you're spotted it's a
relentless chase until they lose sight
of you during my playthrough i had to
continuously traverse emmy patrol zones
as i looked for the way out which in
typical metroid fashion involved
detailed exploration and eventually
earning new abilities to find ways to
reach what seemed like inaccessible
areas going into emmy areas for me were
initially frenetic bought for the exit
affairs with any mistimed jumps or
missed ledges ending in quick emmy
assisted death but that frantic feeling
eventually subsided into a more
controlled tension as the game forced
more emmy interactions in one area i had
to stand on a switch for a certain
amount of time in order to access the
next room this simple task was made
complicated by a pursuing emmy which
meant i had to get enough distance away
from the robot stand on the switch for
as long as i could before bolting and
leading the emmy away so i could return
to the switch again it was thrilling
despite their apparent indestructibility
there are ways to get away from an emmy
and it's another area where dread
manages to ably ratchet up the tension
you can if you're quick enough counter
an enemy attack once it has you in its
grasp much like in metroid samus returns
most enemies i encountered in metroid
dread could be counted just before they
attacked but the window for countering
emmys was especially tiny out of perhaps
the seven times i was caught during my
brief playtime i only managed to counter
once and even then it seemed more like
luck than skill on my part you'll also
be able to completely destroy an emmy in
a sector once you find and defeat that
sector's main control unit and grab a
single use of mega cannon powerup when
you take on an enemy with this power up
your point of view shifts to a close
behind the back view of samus from where
you can aim your fire directly at the
robot's armored head it takes quite a
few shots to first blow away the armor
and then deliver the finishing blow and
the act of holding my nerve and shooting
an enemy as it slowly advanced towards
me was quite a rush
by the time my hands on ended i had
encountered a major boss fight and
earned a new ability that allowed me to
move up certain wars but was those tense
emmy chases that stayed with me well
after my play time it also made me
wonder how emmys will evolve as the game
progresses as previous dread trailers
have shown off different colored emmys
which means this game's most intriguing
enemies very likely have more surprises
the metroid games have always excelled
at creating an underlying mood of unease
and in metroid red it's clear that
unease is meant to boil over into a
persistent constant tension
you